at the World Economic Forum this year
there has been much talk about economic
justice for some the German Finance
Minister Wolfgang schäuble doesn't
really fit this mold he has helped many
countries in the EU zone to pass painful
reforms and that has often led to him
being accused of lacking solidarity in a
conversation with DW director-general
Peter Limbach Shora had to defend
himself
solidarity doesn't mean constantly
handing out money you don't have
that's called occurring debts rather
solidarity means solving problems and
constantly justifying your solutions
Charlotte believes austerity is the only
way that countries like Spain will once
again be able to borrow and he believes
austerity is the only way to maintain
the confidence of the market Europe
doesn't have to become Germany but it
has to remain strong if it wants to have
a place in a globalized world it can't
put its relatively high social security
bill if it can't maintain a basic level
of economic competitiveness and Minda
standard on victory of spearhead of 32
country but everyone at the Davos
conference is interested about how
things will develop in the future not
just the Europeans in today's globalized
world the success or failures of large
economic bloc's such as Europe have
global knock-on effects